on this episode we go rare Sunday late
afternoon
[Music]
[Music]
not
this is
[Music]
what up YouTube
good to see you about through ups for
245 the askgaryvee show live thanks hey
Wendy Rock tries it reached me the [ __ ]
out
what up Instagram periscope you Facebook
YouTube
everybody's live you ready yeah alright
2:45 everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 245 of the
askgaryvee show
we've got all sorts of things going on
YouTube Facebook periscope and Instagram
life and Facebook Facebook is where
we're getting the questions from here
today hope Facebook on two computers and
that's it we'll see if we can match the
intensity of the last episode that
created the epic piece of content with
Taylor and he's not even waiting he's
getting right into it I'm cool with that
phone numbers on Facebook if you want to
be on the show let's get it over hey man
it's Gary Vee how are you
no way how are you coming I didn't catch
your name and put down the US but
screams you can yeah definitely it's a
Kenneth Hanover Kenneth cool man how are
you way from I'm from Tarrytown
originally my grace your New York loved
it man I went to a great toy show in
Tarrytown in 1993 and bought a lot of
old-school Star Wars manuals and made a
fuckload of money so I love Tarrytown
that's awesome motors out over at the
Hilton or something yeah it was actually
20 24 years ago they still be shown that
I don't know if they still do shows
there I mean that's like literally like
right down the street from my parents
house I love it so what's your question
bro
okay so I'll kind of get to it um so I
uh
over this past year I was working at a
startup and then recently got laid off
or was made redundant and yes member a
bit here okay and I kind of like I've
got a point my library's like in sales
and I was like pretty into it you know
like all right you know this is working
for me and then no no like I just
suddenly was like not that excited about
it so now I'm trying to figure out what
not excited not
because of the gut-punch of the layoffs
were not excited prior to it I think not
excited fryer to it I was working I was
working at Yelp
yep and what's a lot of high-volume
outbound cold call trail yep yep and you
know it's just one of those things that
I started doing I got into it just
because you know I need to be making
money and shirt job yep
and you know I came to a point where is
like another opportunity presented
itself and I was just like all right
well you know maybe this would be
different I'll be in a startup it'll be
I'll have a lot more autonomy over my
day and I kind of just found out that
I'm getting pushed back at that same
direction which is just like a bunch of
outbound cold call you know sales calls
and I I don't know I just like firm for
me it was just like it's not like I was
like living at Groundhog Day where I was
basically just like waking up doing the
same thing over and over and over again
you are yeah
and so I guess like now I'm at a
situation where I just moved back home
with my parents and I guess I'm trying
to figure out what what's going to
excite me are like what what my next
step should be because I think going and
continuing to do the same thing is
obviously not not going to be good for
my self-esteem or Kotori mentally like I
think I've kind of at this point decided
what do I like I don't want to do this
but at the same time I don't know what
it is that I do want to do like you kind
of figure it out can you afford an D
watch us in knock that over uh are you
in a place where you can afford to go
and taste a lot of different things I
think of this like food people always
like what's my passion what do I like to
do I'm like I don't know like if you
only eat pizza and hot dogs how do you
not you know know if you know foie gras
or or sushi or lemon soup is your
favorite food of all time Lord lemons
who came from but you know you want a
place where you can go and try doing
different things and if you can't go get
a nine-to-five job that pays your basic
life away and then spend your 5:30 p.m.
to midnight tasting other things in
start-up land or internships that's the
actual practical answer to solve this
question did we lose him is that him
call back hello
hello yeah he's done all right let's
move on yeah I mean you know sorry lost
the call where where you go when you
don't know what you want to do is you
have to try to do things I mean it's not
super complicated so if you've got a
trust fund or if you save some money or
if you're living you know ghetto and
don't give a [ __ ] and live with 11
roommates and you know then and can
afford to just cancel it out in is uh
what you got to do is you've got to go
and fly things you've got to try
operations you got to try sales you've
got to try all these different things
that's really just the only option out
there and so you've got to put yourself
in a position whether being humble and
and ghetto to go and try things or maybe
your luck in the luxury spot where you
can go to leave it it's really the only
way you're not going to find out by
guessing Lisa with the ground level
cookie business hello hey Lisa's Gary
Dean you're on the askgaryvee show shut
up are you serious I am not joking Lisa
that's crazy
harness awesome awesome so what's your
question so I literally just started a
very ground level on cookie business
about a year ago I literally just did it
out of out of fun it was a hobby and I
was in full-time school for my
cosmetology license and I'm
unfortunately went through a divorce
okay but this cookie business has taken
all and has become more than just a
hobby
within less than a year I've gotten
about 400 fans just on Facebook so I'm
wondering if I should take it to the
next level and kind of get like my LLC
and really branded and how to kind of go
about doing that on a professional level
well there is no it's great about
entrepreneurship
there's no amateurs or professional like
getting an LLC doesn't mean your
professional there's plenty of people
that don't have an LLC that are making
tons of money you know they should get
an LLC when they get to a certain scale
for legal and financial purposes but
don't think of this as like
graduating to like I get an LLC and I
take it serious you've already done the
hard part you actually did something
right so like so are we talking about
you make cookies and sell them I do
they're on their custom cookie so it's a
it's a basically a sugar cookie which
everybody absolutely loves yep um and
then I cut so I don't rub them morning
sitting here and I don't eat sugar
cookies tell them Jordan but I get
everything right and then you come in
and design on top of them right like the
rock space so guys like it yeah yeah
then it's all hand design and I haven't
done anything where I print anything if
I give it early on how much and how much
are the cookies and how much have you
made so far I'm averaging right now
about $600 a month in cookies and how
much profit and how much profit is that
like 400 like 300 is pretty profitable
right it's very profitable like it's
very profitable right now yeah yeah you
know I'm and I'm only doing it part-time
you love it I do I honestly do I think
that it's amazing that a cookie can
bring so much joy to somebody's life I
feel like I need to touch people's lives
and it's really cool and I very fastly
grew outside of the friends and family
you know it's I mean there's people on
Facebook who don't know who I am and
I've never met them if they've never
tasted the cookie before that are
ordering dozens of cookies for me and
spending hundreds of dollars with me on
to get up what do you guys all laughing
about I'm curious it's cool to hear that
guys you meet people make a million
dollars a year selling cookies and
brownies and like baked goods i [ __ ]
love baked goods why do you think that
that Gary existed listen I think I think
this is a real business I think here's
what you need to think about are you
going to be capable of hiring other
people like you want to MIT like right
now it's a hobby and it's fun and you
get a lot of relief and probably you
know even the way you set it up you
decided to bring up the divorce so maybe
was an escapism for you you loved the
art part you need to figure out if
you're a business person because if
you're just the artist it's going to get
to a place where it's now it's
definitely a business but I mean I've
been in direct sales for about ten years
well then you should then you should
definitely build this
I guarantee based on let me rephrase my
intuition says that you have the
capability of building a million dollar
revenue minimum cookie business if you
go hard and fast and you know if you're
making 70% 80% margin that's
life-changing so you know I think you
should very much here so you can I don't
see what permission you're looking for
for me I think you should you should can
you afford to go all-in um at this point
I don't I don't know but I think that's
where I'm where do I go how to do it
perform like in no no it's very simple
what are we going to say what you have
to look for what do I need like an
investor now I need know I knew your
loan like not like now you need sex you
need to create it you need to be making
[ __ ] cookies right now putting out
content not [ __ ] being on social
media and watching my show yes Gary I
know this but I mean ah but I mean I
really believe that's true right like
here's what you need to do and whatever
30 and of what everybody needs to do
when they've got something brewing but
they're not in a practical place you
have to jump all in they need to
sacrifice every other second so that you
could get the cookie sales from 600 a
month to six thousand a month and let
you leap like I want people if they
really love it let me paint you a
scenario that may not be yours but I'm
trying to give value to everybody if
you're making 80 thousand a year right
and you live on an 80 thousand a year
kind of budget right like your rent and
everything and you've got something
that's making six hundred dollars a
month like selling you know pictures or
or cookies or whatever you're doing and
you want to go all-in you've never had
such happiness
step one figure out how to bring your
expenses to a $60,000 a year life right
you don't need nice shoes girl yesterday
in Vancouver I'm like you don't need
those nice shoes stop talking [ __ ] right
you know maybe you move if you if you
don't own a home and get lower rent like
literally you get to 60,000 and then you
spend every other second and I mean
every second you go to sleep at 1:00 in
the morning and you wake up at 6:00
because you're baking cookies and you're
building up your Instagram and your pic
Pinterest my life is good so like to me
that's like just go pop committed until
you get to a place where you can afford
to make the jump and that's what you do
and then you start and then and once you
make that jump let's say you got it up
to 5,000 a month because you
so that is up to 60,000 but you're doing
it part-time if you loved it and you
were good enough to get it to that
60,000 when you make the jump and your
whole day is that that 60,000 gets to a
buck 80 real fast
ah got it
yeah off a good luck I think yeah you're
welcome
it was awesome I mean that that's a
thing like like too many people talk out
of both sides of their mouth they're
like they want this new thing I think
she's got it I'm not talking about her
they want this new thing but they they
got a big of Ceuta loans they got rent
but what a lot of people have is a
lifestyle and it's too fancy compared to
what they want everybody's rushing left
yesterday I saw a bunch of 19-year olds
with nice suits they need to be living
in the [ __ ] basement with three
friends and saving that three thousand
dollars and putting it back in your
business we lack old-school practicality
in today's new environment Ryan that's
what needs to happen save money invest
money invest in your business that
you're holding on to you
Ryan is a garyvee Nerney askgaryvee show
get hurry all the color man super well
bro how are you I love on my name's Ryan
I'm in Ottawa Ontario Canada meet Auto
gotta be a yeah we're an automotive
lifting fire okay like auto trader
kijiji you can sell your cars on our
site
I understand so we're looking at getting
some funding and we're a start-up with
two and a half years ago a platform and
we're looking to do some marketing so if
you had $20,000 I want to get the best
bang for your buck I'd watch some your
stuff thank you yes yeah and do you know
when you run Facebook ads on in the auto
industry you can actually tap into pole
kada you're right um I've heard some of
that about that done some research on it
stopped doing research will start doing
spend all $20,000 on pole Teta back
facebook ads awesome great yeah that's
that's amazing is there anything else
you would do like any other market shell
just hammer it into Facebook yep that's
amazing yeah I really appreciate that is
there anything else nice videos I should
watch no of yours now but those nope
Facebook
whole kata thanks guys for being
straight up Gary really love your stuff
love me too man see ya when you have the
best pant pulk data is an industry data
source that actually tracks people and
knows that they're in the market for a
Sudan you can literally know somebody's
in the market for a four-wheel vehicle
like and of course the data is not a
hundred percent pure but it's doing
search queries it's doing people that
I've got like serving it's just going
data you're literally getting into
people's schemes that are [ __ ] works
in my car instead of what all these car
people do is by billboards and on
commercials all the times you never know
when somebody's in the market for car
yes you don't know if in the market cars
of 1984 hey bro it's Gary beer on the
askgaryvee show
Jose yes I are you sensational in you I
are you I'm great bro this is Gary
Vaynerchuk from the askgaryvee show
I can't believe I'm on the phone with
you right now you are man
unbelievable I'm a huge trip Thank You
Man I appreciate it what can I help you
with let me get to this point uh so I
feel like the markets going to take in
the next few months nobody sees it I see
it because I've been looking at patterns
basically all my life embedded in real
estate since I was 18
okay I'm doing great this is great so
it's weird for me to be the guy that
says they think they're about to think
and let's close [ __ ] down okay do you
think I should be looking for different
avenues to compensate for that or just
save for the best time I say so you're
in the real estate business how do you
think the real estate markets about to
collapse
yep so I think you're 100 percent right
now whether it's three months from now
or a year I'm not sure could be eighteen
months you know as well as I do you can
never fully predict for it so one to one
thing you should do so do you buy
properties and flip them or do you like
are you like a real estate agent and
sell and sell like sell homes like what
do you do correct I do residential sales
and I'm also an investor as well well
and you believe it's going to believe
it's going to tank
you should divest into cash okay like I
mean what are you going to talk about it
and then [ __ ]
said on assets when they go down 30 to
50 percent Shh no I'd have to pretty
much tell everything on that's how you
do it okay okay I sold my drive so much
I sold my Twitter stock when I thought
it wasn't going to be as valuable and I
was right that was a good idea
yeah okay with other other southern
mysterio up well yeah I mean so bro your
residential wise how can it reduce
during the night time you so your left
forward about your investment because
you don't have that much capital tied in
you're more worried about losing the
commissions that come in from selling
homes I'm worried about more of
producing money and during the best
times because capital is fine I could
sell off being misses that I have and
I'll be perfectly fine for like five
years but I'm talking about building
yeah so I mean whenever there's a down
market there's up opportunities
elsewhere so I mean look listen have you
been doing the real estate thing from
were you involved in 2079
twelve years I got in a no-fuss wait
like 120 grand my first year and then
everything cooker [ __ ]
so what did you learn where was the
money made during that [ __ ] at the
beginning of them at when everything
took a dump that's when a lot of people
who made their money as when the market
was no right so I think I think you need
to use a pattern recognition of what
happened then right so what are the
angles one of the opportunities or you
know do you take a reprieve from that
market get all your cash out and then
deploy it into other areas that you
think are going up during that time
right or do you take that cash right if
you just told me you're going to sell
everything and you're good for five
years then I would sell it take that
cash wait for it to happen and then buy
[ __ ] on a nickel on the dollar so that
when the next come up comes you make a
real [ __ ] fortune when I stated here
and I was going to do it it's just you
know if you going against a prediction
you know everything is the unknown but
as far as fighters go in the market it's
always a safe that's exactly right so
like like what too many of my friends do
is they love to claim that they got it
right but their actions didn't match
they were thrilled that they said that
they predicted the real estate market
was going to
yes they didn't sell their seven homes
so they feel good like I told you over a
beer but their [ __ ] bank account got
punched in the mouth yeah I'd rather you
not predict [ __ ] and [ __ ] sell off
and make money correct cool
thanks okay exactly I don't know I
appreciate the call no worries brother
okay Jose I mean look that was a phone
call because and I get it like it's
scary to sell off you can afford to hold
it through the whole way through you can
do that but you know if you're still in
the early part of your career selling at
a high taking the cash and then catching
it on the low that's just smart then
it's not super confusing the problem is
everybody you know it's really fun the
prediction when you have no money lost
everybody loves to Monday Morning
Quarterback everybody loves to tell me
how to run this business let me make
them the CEO for a week see them quiver
and fold like a cheap [ __ ] chair is
it fro get out of here Rob Jer
what's up Jerry I know man how are you
I'm doing well how you make it out
tremendous house Philly Philly is
looking up and up right now I love it
real estate markets on fire I love it
what's cookin breakfast question is
there ever such a thing as putting out
too much content the answer is yes in
the micro algorithm game of marketing
and no in the branding game of marketing
so I say no all right how bout uh dude
give me let's roll this is a very simple
question the people that are deepest
knowledgeable about what's going on in
social content will tell you there's
certain platforms and certain algorithms
that you don't want to put out too much
content because it can hurt your I tell
you sure but what happens is you lose
certain awareness but the volume makes
upward plus you might have not put out
that one [ __ ] piece of content that
changed your life it's a it's a
massively interesting debate probably
even amongst my own team I just believe
what I believe I just don't think you
can put out it by the way there's
another thing it's called your talent on
the content like if you're a one-trick
pony and you're not interesting and you
can't bring value well how much content
can you put out which is why documents
over create became such a big thing for
me because it allows people to put out
more content than they were putting out
do you ever think you're burning out the
odor do you Sharon yeah people that
you're rude I think I'm adding more
people that I'm losing and I think I'm
burning some people out right which is
bound to happen but the people stick
around if you're not twenty-five hundred
videos in are due to but
micro content everywhere else where we
need to be in there is the other thing
is you got to remember the other thing
is that all this is important not
everybody overtly if I was a 16 year old
blogger like blue eyed pretty boy I'd
have 7 million fans on YouTube like
certain platforms over indexed you know
you and I are are in a demo and have
been doing at a time like you know we
still don't live in a world where a ton
of 40 50 and 60 year olds are consuming
YouTube all the time so you're going to
have your audiences but you know I I
don't I'm worried where you're going
with this is and we're a lot of people
going with this is people that have been
in the game for two three four five six
seventy years you have plateaus I've had
them and and and but it's almost like an
actor right like like John Travolta
Saturday Night Fever whatever big star
of the late 70s and early 80s then
nothing from 83 to 94 95 and then pulp
fiction back right Mickey Warren slick
like I think of it like I think of it
that way
like you might just be hot for a year
and then cool for you know three and
then one piece of content can change
everything simon Sinek somebody I've
known for a long time been game putting
out content for five years his interview
the other day we [ __ ] on Millennials
disagree when viral is [ __ ] now he's
here you know like I mean you know yeah
makes all sense I'm not stopping anytime
soon but is the thing the thing I would
tell you and the thing if you look at my
behavior is maybe you need to think
about other platforms of being really
aggressive maybe maybe you would have
really really really popped in 10 second
form on Instagram and
and vine or snapchat videos like the one
thing I would tell you is is always
hardcore taste the other stuff and I
know you do do micro content other
places but sometimes make put another
flag down not just on YouTube what's
going on with you and Facebook video are
you hardcore putting it all there - I've
been hardcore edit those videos gonna
start putting it up okay okay I've been
part of stuff of the beta tester David
how about how about hiring how about
hiring an intern who loves photography
to transcribe your video and make it to
blog form yeah that's I transcribe all
the most videos we put these
transcriptions up on YouTube we put them
all over the place because I hear the
transcriptions get traction on YouTube
though I haven't seen any bump from that
yet how about how about how about the
part that really works on YouTube how
hardcore have you been about
collaborations collaborations has been
difficult at this juncture because not a
lot of other people to work with on my
side sure there is you need to figure
out how to integrate your narrative into
other people [ __ ] sure the on
photography makes total sense no no only
beyond photography that's the punchline
er like there's nothing but people like
vlogging it like every single blogger on
YouTube is in play for you because
photography with your plays good boy
thank you what was your going yeah
that's why I do the show one more get
ahead are you spending money on YouTube
I was we've stopped right we're kind it
was so hardcore
Instagram and Facebook right now so I'm
just but I believe in say in YouTube ads
and believe there's value in it but I
would collab the [ __ ] out of your life
you should literally email and reach out
to every single vlogger on YouTube which
will take you the rest of your life and
your children's lives
alright thank you you got a brother
that's really good advice
the collabos really or the game like
bring values that's a tiny done amazing
photographer
go to shoot somebody any families are
vlogging they have tons of people email
them say I want to come on on shoot and
I'll take photography of your family you
have some great family portraits and
he'll get 4000 subscribers and a fly to
Ohio
all right solid shell good advice this
one I like there you liked it right just
like a good solid Sunday afternoon while
everybody's like scratching their ass
watching basketball right now will pump
it out [ __ ] you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
[Music]